>>Eddy: Hi, my name is Eddy Kim.
I'm the site planner, and thank you
for letting us propose the plan,
on behalf of the city council--
>>Narrator: The city of
Yorktown is considering proposals
from several real estate
developers for plans
to revitalize the blighted
neighborhood of Elmwood.
>>Eddy: We plan on putting a
lake or big kind of like pond
in the middle as our focal point.
>>Narrator: Elmwood is a fictional
place, but many communities
across the country
face similar problems.
>>Student: Actually,
the number's going to be
about one point five million.
>>Narrator: These students
from Alameda High School
in northern California are presenting
solutions at the culmination
of a three week project based
learning exercise called Urban Plan.
>>Paula: Urban Plan was designed
to take required economics
and required government classes out
of their silos and put them together
in a way that students of a
sudden had that, "Oh, I get it.
So I aced my standardized tests.
I know how to write an answer
about supply and demand.
But when I do Urban Plan, now I
understand why I can't afford to live
in the town I grew up in."
>>Teacher: And so I just want to
reiterate that there isn't like,
"Oh yeah, you have to put in
tons of parks, or you have to put
in skyscrapers to generate
all this money."
There are many possible answers.
That's the point of reality.
>>Narrator: Developed at UC Berkeley,
the Urban Land Project is available
to schools in many cities
through the Urban Land Institute's
district councils.
>>Teacher: And then you've
got neighborhood letters,
which are the interest groups that
have so far stepped forward and said,
"Hey, this is what we want here."
>>Narrator: It is a rigorous
project that addresses most
of the state economics
curriculum standards,
like marginal cost benefit,
allocation of goods and services,
and the role of incentives.
>>Teacher: The dry goods
building, it's a historic building,
and you can read a little
bit about it and what kind
of uses you can do with it.
There are limits on this
building, you have to do this.
This building, you can
do whatever you want.
>>Narrator: To make
it easy on teachers,
the Land Institute provides
everything they need for the project,
from outside expert
volunteers to laptops and Legos.
>>Paula: All the materials
are paid for, the Lego kits,
the teacher's guide and lesson
plans, the curriculum handbooks,
the site plans, everything,
delivered to the teacher.
>>Teacher: The idea that you
can't really be entirely creative,
and there are these rigid
requirements on building heights,
appearances, locations, is realistic.
So you're thinking creatively, and
you've just got to think differently.
>>Narrator: Students use
the Legos to create a model
of their new neighborhood.
The computers are loaded with the
sophisticated software they need
to solve complex dilemmas.
>>It's too high.
>>Yeah, it's way too high.
>>Student: How do we kill our percent
but still make the city go up?
>>Narrator: They are
broken into teams of five
and teach student serves in a
specific role, like site planner,
director of marketing,
or neighborhood liaison.
>>Student: My role as the
financial advisor was basically just
to make profit for both the
investors and the city, so that's--
>>Narrator: They must become
experts in their individual roles
and share their ideas with the group.
>>Rob: This project has
things that are going to stick
with the students more in their
life, working with different people
that they didn't like,
speaking in front of strangers,
thinking about something from
a different point of view.
You know, thinking about
design, appreciating the world
that they live in,
politically, aesthetically,
working on a spreadsheet.
>>Student: It's a neighborhood
retail, for example,
the absorption rate is two point
eight six, which is pretty close
to our upper limit, 'cause the
optimum absorption rate is three,
and midrise office building,
we actually went over that,
so it's a problem we need to solve.
>>Narrator: Students must deal
with all kinds of problems,
like balancing parking
lots with open space.
>>Student: I think we could
make this park smaller,
this park is really big.
>>Narrator: Generating
sufficient returns.
>>Student: We're making ten million,
six hundred and fifty-six thousand
and losing three million--
>>Narrator: And addressing
the conflicting priorities
of neighborhood interest groups.
>>Student: I don't know, if
we put in a homeless shelter,
and the neighborhood alliance
gets mad, then they're just going
to be bothering city
council to death, you know.
They're just going to
be knocking on the door,
"What are all these
homeless people doing here?"
>>Narrator: In the second week,
real estate professionals who serve
as facilitators come to class
to discuss the initial designs,
sometimes providing a
harsh reality check.
>>Student: Affordable housing,
right now it's fifty-fifty
for one building.
>>Marisita: Fifty-fifty, okay.
>>I don't like to tell
them what to do ever.
I really would like
to ask hard questions.
If they have the homeless
shelter, I immediately say,
"What difficulties
would that pose to you?"
>>If they don't have it, I
ask them immediately, "Oh,
so you moved the homeless shelter.
Where are the homeless going to be?"
>>And you can deal with
the issues both ways,
but the important things here is to
deal with the issue, confront it.
>>Student: We're supposed to
follow like the primary goals,
and one of them is to remove the
blighting influences, and we thought
that the homeless shelter
just brought everything down.
>>Jacqueline: Going into the project,
we think, "Oh that's easy, you know.
I can just put some Legos here.
That represents a building
and it's all good."
But then you really have
to think about the effects
of what it's going to do.
>>Teacher: What's going
to be in these stores?
Have you thought about any of that?
What's going to pull
people down here?
>>Student: Restaurants, Boutiques.
>>Student: Coffee shops.
>>Jacqueline: Also we had the
experts come in and question us.
Some of them were harsh.
Some of them were a lot nicer about
it, but either way, we learned a lot
from all of them, I'd say.
>>They got-- see, this way--
>>Seventy-five percent.
>>We have less opposites--
>>Now it's eighty--
>>-- is a lot smaller.
>>We also have a midrise, okay?
>>Student: Oh yeah,
we had the midrise.
Is it a midrise?
>>Dong-Jin: The project as a whole,
it gets you ready for the real world.
Just looking at the book,
it gets very tedious,
like you're just looking in a book.
You're memorizing facts and stuff.
But once you learn how to
actually use those facts,
you get a deeper understanding and
you can better interpret questions,
and so you build up
really useful skills.
>>Student: Our group is called
Mindsweepers Corporations,
and our vision is to
have a very diverse city
that have a more suburban feel.
In our first block, we have retail
such as Macy's and Barnes & Noble's
for the college students.
>>Narrator: Presentation time is
limited to ten to twelve minutes,
with each student speaking from the
perspective of their individual role.
>>Student: All right, I'm
the financial analyst.
My name's Daniel--
>>Narrator: A question and answer
period follows each proposal.
>>Paula: Is it going to be an
animal shelter or an office?
>>Student: It's divided
into two, and--
>>Paula: It's true that
there's no right answer,
so we may challenge
or question a lot.
>>So a nonprofit office that
acts as an animal shelter?
>>Student: The way that you say it,
it makes it sound like there's going
to be dogs jumping
on the office tables.
>>Paula: Yup.
>>Student: We have nonprofit--
>>Paula: That's how council sees it.
>>Student: The nonprofit
in one section and office
in one section, so like--
>>Paula: Let me just stop you
about the logistics of it.
What I'm interested in is,
so you're putting in an SPCA,
which I don't see either the city
or the neighborhood requested,
and you're not putting in a
daycare center, a police substation,
any of the things that
we offered to subsidize
or that the neighborhood requested.
Is that correct?
>>Yes.
>>Yeah, that would be correct.
>>Paula: That's correct, thank you.
>>Daniel: My group decided
that it would be more important
to include other things
that weren't in the RFP.
I was just sitting at the computer,
typing in what they wanted.
My job was to make sure
that we made money.
>>The city liaison's job was to say,
"You're not meeting all
of the RFP requirements.
That was a big problem with our plan.
>>Student: The retail,
we think is a good mix,
because we will have coffee shops and
Laundromats and small businesses--
>>Paula: Because the students
are assigned a specific role,
the teacher can evaluate how well a
student understands and has worked
on this role by the input
they're bringing into the class
and the presentation they make.
>>So a good student on a
weak team can still get an A.
>>Student: Victoria Row is
forty percent nonprofit.
Ten percent of that is
going towards artists,
which is one of the
demands of the community.
>>Narrator: While students
gain an appreciation
for the challenges
involved in development,
teacher Rob Sultanan thinks
the project offers even more
valuable lessons.
>>Rob: From this project, there
are all these non objective,
nontraditional measure
things that are curiosity,
creativity, teamwork, passion.
So I do it for those reasons, not
because of the economics curriculum.
>>Student: We have
a police substation,
which will watch over the park.
>>Rob: I believe that to be educated
is to be thoughtful, to be wise,
to have perspective, to
step out of your world view,
and that the Urban Plan
accomplishes all those things.
>>Student: We wanted to give
people a sense of place,
so we put the businesses near the
businesses, as you can see here.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org.